do you have regrets of course I regrets  I also have regrets that I think will  really help people that I am ready to  talk about which is no [ __ ] but I  should have went to a couple more High  School parties no [ __ ] I shouldn't  have come home every weekend when I was  in college and worked in the liquor  store I should have did a keg stand or  two here no [ __ ] I should have taken  more vacations in my 20s with my buddies  like I should have had a little more fun  the truth is I'll tell you why that was  all hard for me to say they're micro  micro micro regrets I have nothing in my  body including some of the stuff I'm not  ready to talk about that's like [ __ ] you  know like I'm in pain over this they're  just like little micro regrets and I  answer this because I want people to see  a clear picture on the other side